همم
اولا ماذا تقول في هذه اللحظه ههه
يعني الاحفاد عند ومن اسعد اللحظات اني
اشوف الزملائي لعاشروني ورافقوني ضرب
الاسد من اسعد اللحظات ان تلتقي في الاهل
رغم التغيرات اللي حاصله طبعا على مده 40
سنه ولكن كلياته هذا كان بمثابه انه تغيير
ايجابي وان شاء الله حياتنا تكون
واعطانا راح يكون ايجابي للمرحله القادمه
ماذا يعني ان يتحرر الاسير الى عالم جديد
بالنسبه اليه بعد 40 عاما ماذا يعني ان
تقضي في الاسير 40 عام
فلسطين
على اساسا الرساله مش رساله واحده طبعا
انه
بقدر اقول انه الوفد في الداخلي هو اللي
بيقدر يجمعنا ويوحدنا على اساس انه نتصدى
لكل الهجمات القادمه
في 20 سنه او في 40 سنه انه الامل انه
اخرج واشوف الوطن المتحرك وهذا شيء يعني
اللي كان همم بيفرحني اكثر واكثر لو احنا
دخلنا على جينا على وطن محرر همم
يعني احرار كشعب العالم كلها جميعا
وبما انك تحررت والوطن ليس محررا
كيف
يكون في بعض الناس
يعني مش مكتمل الفرحه لم تكتمل كامله
منذ سنوات وهناك قيود اكثر وهناك تهديدات
بالتضييق على الاسرى اكثر في ظل الحكومه
الحاليه وتولي المتطرف تمر بني كبير
لوزاره الامن القومي ماذا يقولون عن ذلك
ان كان همم التطرف او باكثر تتطرف همم
وتعدينا كل المصاعد لانه الحركه الاثير
الحركه الاسيري لها يعني جواب لكل سؤال
ولكل اعتداء خلينا نسميها
والحركه الاسير دائما دائما واقفه في
المرصاد لكل همم توجهه او عنصريه او هجوم
هذه بتطلب طبعا
على اساس انها توقف مع الحركه الاسيري وهم
يوقفوا كمان نفس الشيء يعني هم يتابعوا
امورهم اللي في الوحده الداخليه كمان نحن
بنادي في الوحده الخارجيه كمان في الوحده
الداخليه تكون كمان كلمه اخيره لوالدتك
الجميله التي انتظرتك كل هذا الوقت
العربي في متسعه همم في حق امي يعني امي
اللي انتظرت يعني 40 عام ووو كان والده
كابلها سبع سنين في الاسير واخوي سنه ونصف
في الاسير واليوم توجهها اخوها ماهر ابنها
ماهر في 40 سنه يعني بتوقع الام من الصابر
الام الحنون الام ال- المخلص
الصبر شكرا